there are two social media universes
over here there are the Facebook's
instagrams and snapchats where life is
full of happiness fun and puppies over
here
there's old joyless LinkedIn where life
is full of resumes productivity tips and
plenty of these types of emails making
fun of LinkedIn is too easy figuring out
what the heck to do with it not so much
evidence according to Pew sixty-one
percent of LinkedIn users only log in
every few weeks I used to be in the same
boat until I dug into some of the new
features and tricks now some parts of
the service are still flat-out
terrible but whether you're happy in
your job or looking for a new one it's
time to make LinkedIn work for you oh
look at this place navigating a corn
maze is easier it's time to stop using
this cluttered website step 1 use the
iOS or Android apps and then customize
your feed what a difference the design
makes and just this week the company is
updating the iPhone app with simpler
navigation sure there are a few more
advanced features on the web but the app
has most of what you need now I'm not
looking for a new job I really like this
one but I'm still checking the app
multiple times a week because I really
like the industry related posts and
articles you can customize the feed even
further by selecting these little dots
then tapping improve your experience and
then selecting their interests I'd also
encourage you to post your own updates
you'll be surprised at how good the
conversation around them can be but news
is still secondary on LinkedIn to
building a network of business contacts
so how exactly you're supposed to do
that let's talk about your outdated
profile right now I command you to go
update your profile and photo yes even
check the profile strength tool hey now
I'm an all-star if you're looking for a
job the most important thing you can do
is write a strong summary don't believe
me believe this expert you want to
include those all-important keywords
when writing your summary after all
LinkedIn is a giant search engine the
last
it's carefully thinking about who you
connect with your LinkedIn experience
will be better if you connect only with
people that have real value to you this
is business
so be choosy all those people you've
accepted can post right into your feed
and send you private messages and when
you ask people to be a contact avoid the
sin of the generic email instead
customize it with a short note sure
parts of LinkedIn are still a complete
mess but with an improved app and some
tweaks of our own you really may find
that it deserves more of your time truth
is we spend much more of our real lives
in this universe than in this one so
anyone want to talk business analytics